calcula el ph en el punto medio de
equivalencia bueno recordemos cuál es el
punto medio de equivalencia mire el
punto de equivalencia es cuando el
titulado que en este caso es el ácido
clorhídrico reacciona completamente con
el sorbato de potasio que es lo que
estamos titulando por lo tanto el punto
medio de equivalencia es el punto en el
que la mitad del sorbato de potasio se
ha convertido en ácido sórbico otra
forma de verlo es ese punto en el que la
concentración del sorbato de potasio y
del ácido sórbico son iguales pero como
relacionamos eso con el ph que otra
información nos han dado para resolver
esto bueno algo que pueden hacer cada
vez que estén atorados en un problema es
preguntarse qué otra información me han
dado bueno ya nos dieron el caa del
ácido sórbico que es 1.7 por 10 a la
menos 5
ahora habrá alguna forma en la que
podamos conectar el caa del ácido
sórbico con el ph en el punto medio de
equivalencia bueno otra cosa que nos
dieron es una serie de fórmulas que
vienen en las primeras páginas de la
sección de respuestas libres ahí vienen
muchas fórmulas sobre equilibrio y las
diferentes notaciones que se usan y una
que nos puede servir mucho es esta de
aquí tal vez la reconozca se conoce como
la ecuación de henderson hasselbeck y no
es muy difícil de comprobar la porque
viene directamente de la definición del
caa y luego simplemente se reordenan los
términos se aplica aún menos logaritmo
en ambos lados y bueno yo los invito a
que vean esos vídeos en khan academy si
tienen curiosidad aquí lo importante es
que nos conecta con el ph relaciona el
ph con el pkk y las concentraciones de
un ácido y de su base conjugado entonces
como hacemos la relación aquí bueno
en el punto medio de equivalencia las
concentraciones del ácido y de la base
con jugada son iguales así que esto se
cancela y nos queda uno y el logaritmo
de uno es igual a cero
entonces en el punto medio de
equivalencia el ph es igual al pk
y cuál es el pk a bueno ya sabemos cuál
es el k
miren el k es igual a vamos a ver a
recuerden es el caa del ácido sórbico
entonces el k y del ácido sórbico es 1.7
por 10 a la menos cinco 1.7 por 10 a la
menos 5 entonces entonces el caa es
igual a 1.7 por 10 a la menos 5 y cuando
hablamos de caá estamos hablando de la
constante de disociación del ácido por
eso este valor corresponde al ácido
sórbico y de cualquier manera
estas dos concentraciones son igual
entonces si queremos conocer el pecado
simplemente hay que calcular el menos
logaritmo de esto entonces el pk a es
igual a menos el logaritmo de base 10
del k.o y esto es igual a el menos
logaritmo de base 10 de 1.7 por 10 a la
menos 5 y esto a que es igual usemos la
calculadora
vamos a ver menos logaritmo que es este
botón que por defecto es el logaritmo de
base 10 logaritmo menos logaritmo de 1.7
por 10 a la menos 5 y esto es igual a
bueno es aproximadamente igual a 4.77
esto es aproximadamente igual a 4.77
entonces como en este caso el ph es
igual al pecado el ph es igual a esto
que obtuvimos